for peter king i'm not gonna throw him
into this peter king joins us here on
the rich eisen show i'm susie schuster
in for rich eisen
i'm gonna spare you that yesterday peter
we um we spent a lot of time talking
about benefer
because we were waiting to see whether
aaron rodgers would show up again
and uh i mean if you want to opine on
benefit you can because chris is really
worried about that
right now really how would you feel
right now if you're alex rodriguez
really you know the the the boyfriend
that won't go away
uh comes back and all of a sudden you're
yesterday's news
that's not supposed to happen to the
great a-rod oh peter who cares it's
a-rod
he's a yankee get out of here it's
almost like she treated him like jason
veritek did
exactly exactly exactly
you heard it here he treated him like
alex verdugo treated that baseball last
night
oh my god what a [ __ ] hey and alex
rodrigo has been homer in about a
hundred years i know
that was i know it was awesome
apparently neither has a rod but
whatever
so he hit a home run to right field over
the bullpen
in fenway on a change up is pretty
pretty good accomplishment so good good
for verdugo who
i must say for most of this year has
been sinking my rotisserie team
glad he's glad he's coming alive at the
right time you should have picked up
[ __ ]
i hey i had tk for a while but then he
went over 100
and i dropped tk before he uh started to
become ricky henderson so
yeah sorry i was too busy watching
shohei last night
i'm sorry i i i stopped and i watched
amazing
peter and i were watching the best team
in the american league sorry yeah
well whatever whatever hi peter how
are you so good to have you back on
again hey susie i need to ask you this
question
oh god i'm talking to rich the other day
about this incredible
bizarre awful experience of getting
covet after being vaccinated
and he said you actually found out that
your daughter was covered positive
when you were on the plane back to los
angeles
imagine how you must feel you've got to
leave your husband
who's got coveted in a hotel room in
boston
and in mid-flight you find out that your
your seven-year-old daughter is positive
i mean what an incredible
run of emotions you must have had and
the guy next to me
started to use his mask as an eye patch
so i had to yeah oh yeah so i had
luckily i had a
i had a um i had a gin and tonic in my
hand
so i had a little bit of liquid courage
so i threw it over his head
yeah pretty much uh you know peter i
gotta tell you it was crazy it was um
really uh a mind-blowing experience but
if i was to start bench or cut
i would probably start taylor
i would bench rich sorry honey and i
would cut the guy next to me but
it was crazy but luckily luckily the
vaccinations kept him out of the
hospital
and they did their job and here's what's
crazy i i
have been perfectly fine so my
vaccination worked just great
so who knew maybe i'm superhuman i don't
know just saying
whatever i just think i just think the
whole vaccine thing now
i'm i look i'm glad rich is talking
openly about this because
there will be a segment of our society i
believe as tom brady said about 40
there will be a segment of our society
that essentially
uh will say see rich eisen got the
vaccine
and then he got coveted the vaccine does
no good
which is nonsensical because as rich
said the vaccine
probably kept him from going on a
ventilator because
this variant struck him very very hard
and
imagine how it would have struck him if
he didn't have the vaccine
and i have to tell you that my husband
being a lifelong yankee fan
the red sox took great care of him in
boston and so did
believe it or not yep wow the red sox is
really nice
yeah and mass general can't say enough
about them
mit sequencing is his uh his results and
you're absolutely right peter i mean
how lucky are we and he's back sitting
in the chair in connecticut doing tokyo
gold on peacock and having the time of
his life
having the most fun since sportscenter i
mean he's just he's a highlight machine
and
you know without that vaccine he who
knows where he could be but you know
i guess you have no idea where i stand
on the matter
i have a lot of ideas i think we stand
as one
i i i think we do peter king here on the
rich eisen show i'm susie schuster in
for rich
we might as well talk about aaron
rodgers because the most of the world is
so
we saw him coming in looking like blade
runner today looking very relaxed in his
kevin chill shirt from the office
i'm curious to you to hear from you your
thoughts on this and
where this will end up if you were to
forecast and how things are changing for
the packers what's the end run here
well you know look i'm gonna i'm gonna
begin this at the beginning where uh
i've
i've thought and i wrote this in the
last column before i went on vacation
that
really the only solution is is a
two-state
solution um you know that
rogers agrees to give them this one year
and then the packers agree to trade him
uh in the in the off season next year
and that apparently is exactly what it
is
the reason that the reason that i i
believe that that was the best way
is because i think after all the
pressure
and look aaron rodgers is a passive
aggressive guy
uh he was very angry at the packers will
never trust
him all that other stuff but he also
there's there's two other huge factors
he he loved most everything about green
bay
you know the fans the history and i mean
i walked the field with him a couple of
years ago doing a bart star
story star was it was struggling so much
and we walked the field and at one point
he looked up
at the uh ring of honor there and he
said hopefully i'll have my
name up there one one time and
i said to him i don't think you have to
worry about that and he said we'll see
but you could tell
that that was something that really
meant a lot to him and
i don't think he wanted to burn bridges
i think that's part of this
and i think he also figured right at the
end uh because
i mean as adam schefter reported and i
thought reported
superbly yesterday you know this this
basically
came down to the end this this was a
late
compromise i think and so now as we sit
here
it's very very clear that the packers
understood
a month or so ago that they would be
willing to compromise and to make is say
if aaron plays one
more year uh and he still wants out
they'll get him out uh and aaron i think
finally came to that realization
the last thing about this i think was
really important is that
look i think the last thing that aaron
wants to do
is sit there all year and he and look
he's a
he's a guy who can avoid uh getting
caught up in the day-to-day stuff
but i don't think anybody likes to have
his name and his reputation fricaseed
for an entire football season
and honestly i think that's probably
what would have happened
if he didn't report to green bay and
said he was sitting out the year
there's no doubt about it for somebody
who is so low-key like that that he
wouldn't
wouldn't want to go through that also in
making a plan for the next stop he
wouldn't want to take that baggage with
him
how has tom brady and what he's done
changed how all quarterbacks of a
certain
ilk look at how they can start
programming their futures
susie during the super bowl last year
cameras focused twice on russell wilson
um
at least one time sitting with roger
goodell and i think the other time was
on the field but
when he was sitting with roger goodell
up in his box
uh russell wilson you know look like his
dog
just died and i heard
later on that he was miserable that
weekend because he looks down at the
field and said
tom brady created this
tom brady created an exit from new
england
a 22-point super bowl win
just by the sheer audacity of saying
i'm not going to finish my career in new
england i want to go somewhere
where i'm going to have a say about a
lot of things
i.e antonio brown let's just say
even though he didn't dictate that it
was clear that the team acceded to that
once they saw how important it was to
tom
and so i think all veteran quarterbacks
who are a little bit unhappy with one
thing or another about where they are
all veteran quarterbacks look at tom
brady and say
i salute you because you want it out
you got out you did it in a classy way
look there's going to be 10 of the
people in new england who hate brady for
leaving
but the vast majority are going to
salute him
and say you gave us everything that you
had
and just like robert kraft said at the
end you deserve to go and do what you
want in the last year or two or three of
your career
so i think aaron rodgers time will tell
will he ever say that
brady's thing influenced them i don't
know but clearly
any veteran quarterback who's unhappy
should be emboldened by tom brady
peter king here on the rich eisen show i
was listening to dan patrick on the way
in as i always do
and he had matt damon on and he asked
matt damon
if it's the patriots and the bucks in
the super bowl who do you
who do you root for and he of course
said tom brady
and i think that says i think a lot of
people from new england feel that way
i mean i i grew up there i i my brother
is uh and his kids bleed patriot
i guess we'd say blue and but it's it's
it's really interesting because he did
leave
in the classiest of ways has there ever
been a time
in the nfl where the quarterback had so
much
power in making these decisions
not that i know of uh and i think a lot
of it
uh and i'm not saying that that it it
it goes back to free agency in baseball
or power grabs in in basketball
but i do think that we are going to see
a change suzy i think we're going to see
players who are unhappy like aaron
rodgers
and look everybody you'll say today
everybody will say
you know the packers won they got br
they got rogers to come back i won't say
that
the reason i won't say that is that
aaron rodgers
who was in the middle of a of an
extended contract
and being paid a jillion dollars a lot
of that money
up front um basically now has shot his
way out of green bay he's just got to
give him
six months more than he ever wanted to
so
you know to me aaron rodgers is still
going to have
say two to four prime
seasons if he chooses to at
another place let's say denver i think
that seems like
the most logical place for him to go but
we'll see
but he's still going to have two to four
prime seasons
and whatever money he makes it'll be
ridiculous
whatever it is but he's gonna have a
chance to go somewhere and to do what
tom brady did which is
to win a super bowl somewhere else peter
king here on the rich eisen show in your
column football morning in america you
talk about how the bills and the browns
haven't been this good in the same time
in your entire career writing what's so
exciting about what you're seeing there
i mean think about it susie the last
time they each won
a playoff game in the same year before
last year
was in 1964 when one day apart
the bills won the afl championship in
buffalo and the browns won the nfl
championship
in cleveland it's the craziest thing but
in my lifetime this my 38th year
covering the nfl
they've never been this good
entering a season you can't point to one
year
in the last four decades where in pro
football
you look at them and they are both top
five teams entering the season at least
i can
and you know they are i believe this
year now
we might be giving uh cleveland a little
bit too much credit i think everybody
would say buffalo's a top five d
i think we might be giving cleveland a
little bit too much credit but
just remember one thing even though
patrick mahomes missed the fourth
quarter of the divisional game
in kansas city the cleveland browns had
the ball with seven minutes to go
at arrowhead stadium and uh
and a touchdown puts them ahead and
remember
patrick mahomes is not in the game so
you know they they've got a heck of a
chance if they can complete one drive
and i think
everybody still wonders a little bit
even though baker mayfield played well
down the stretch last year
everybody wonders a little bit if they
have truly arrived
i like them a lot i don't see a major
weakness on their team
i think that mayfield needs to be a
little bit more accurate
and he'll he'll really be helped i think
by the return of
odell beckham jr because they missed him
down the stretch they missed
the deep threat that is odell beckham jr
no kidding
no kidding i would be remiss if i didn't
ask you your thoughts on what's
happening down in houston with the
texans and deshaun watson
um you know to sum it up uh obviously
they're going to trade them
i think it is a bad idea
for the texans to trade him now
and i think it is a worse idea for a
team to trade for deshaun watson now
for a couple of reasons i wouldn't touch
deshaun watson until we knew exactly
what was going on
uh with the uh with his myriad court
cases
i mean we still don't know and obviously
it is unlikely but we still don't know
if deshawn watson is going to go away
for a little while
we you know i we all doubt it obviously
uh that he would have to serve time for
anything that he did
uh and certainly he's going to have some
sort of
unless all of these claims are
eventually found to be specious
uh he's going to serve some sort of nfl
sanction
so i don't know how a general manager in
his right mind
knowing what he knows right now could
trade
three ones and something else for
deshaun watson
second secondly i would say as if you're
nick casario
you've got an expansion team right now
you've got the worst team in the nfl
the only way that i would be motivated
to do something
this year i mean before next year the
only way
is if it was either such a humongous
distraction
and it was worth the sanity of your team
and the coaching staff to get them away
that you would sacrifice potentially
one-third of the value
of deshaun watson by by waiting and
getting the adjudication of these cases
done
but i just don't understand any
real logical way that nick casario could
make a trade
soon and it would make any sense for
either side
were you at all surprised that he wasn't
on the commissioner's exempt list
a little bit but i think what that means
is that uh there
are some there there's got to be some
real good reasoning with lisa friel
of the nfl uh the former district
attorney
uh who's doing in charge of the
investigation here
there's got to be a real reason why she
thinks that
either there are holes in the case or
this doesn't rise to the commissioner's
exempt list
plus susie they don't there are no games
being played for seven weeks
or whatever it is six weeks so the nfl
has time
to put him on the commissioner's exempt
list the texans
easily could just say hey deshawn you
know you've reported great
you're not going to get fined but we
don't want you
uh you know around the team right now
it's just
it's just too big of a distraction if
deshawn watson reported in practice with
his team it'd just be
to me anyway it'd just be a circus look
i don't know what's gonna happen
but if if i were david cully and nick
casario
i would it would be like one of those
things where
you know you you report to school you
get your attendance taken
and then they say hey go sit in the
cafeteria for the day
we don't want you around our our kids
not necessarily because
he's a bad influence around his team
it's just obviously right now
too much of a distraction yeah and he
won't have to pay the 50 000
for his lunch either when he does that
yeah
it's july so it's never too early to ask
you who you have as a super bowl
champion this year
i don't know i think susie tomorrow is
my first day in an nfl training camp i'm
going to be in las vegas
uh and i'll see i think 21 teams over
the next month
and i always like to say like to
see what's out there i mean i'll tell
you a couple of years ago i
i might my opinion of the 49ers
skyrocketed
after i went to their camp and they
ended up going to the super bowl that
year
coming off of whatever six or four win
season
um so i don't know i i mean i like the
usual suspects
this year more than in the past i've
liked them
i had kansas city tampa one two when i
did my
um you know power ratings or whatever
they call them uh
in in the spring and i wouldn't waver
from that now
but i might uh a month from now
we should talk in a month and and i'll
tell you exactly
whether anything has changed but i i
think that
the power uh might rest
in the afc because i think top to bottom
right now they're a little bit better
than the nfc
well i'll be more than happy to kick
rich out of the chair in a month and
come back and talk to you again so there
you go
um before we go how's your dog
oh dog is our dog is good our
uh we i we have just spent my wife and i
have
it's our day six and then the last day
of watching our two grandchildren up in
berkeley
uh my daughter and her wife went away uh
for a few days and so this is i i
tweeted this last night i have got such
an incredible amount of respect
for people who have to balance
uh life and raising kids which
i haven't done for like 33 years or
something like that
but just six days of it i say it's
it's incredible the people who are on
the front lines and i simply can't
imagine
doing it in a pandemic where not only
you have to raise your kids but you also
have to be
the teaching assistants too so uh
hats off to every parent who does that
because
i don't know i i could do it if i had to
but wow i wouldn't be very good at it
yeah we we did it for a while with three
and so i will just like to say um thanks
to my nanny thelma first of all
and second of all you're a hero to
grandparents everywhere my mother would
no
sooner stay for six days without helping
my kids
she would bail so fast with that so no
no no
chris you know my mother so fast no
chance she is out
all i can say is this susie we're
delivering
two children back to their parents alive
and that's that's really i mean our job
is done here that's a win
that is amazing peter you're an american
hero
i'm just saying all right thanks a lot
for having me thank you for your time
peter king
and by the way those socks peter go
socks peter hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here